[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a segment where viewers where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
worthy we actually challenged our
viewers see if you can find a mistake in
this otherwise flawless program so far
millions and millions of challengers not
one winner
no one's ever caught us making mistake
well tonight a fan named Michael Lee of
Alameda California says he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
when I was doing a week of shows in
Harlem last year hey Conan big fan of
you Andy and team Coco in your remote
segment filmed at Sylvia's soul food in
Harlem you definitely did catch the real
reason why a Yankees fan was wearing New
York Jets gear and not New York Giants
gear one question for you boy it's
always Yankee Giants you are Yankee Jets
you know what I think Giants suck this
year and you switch to that team
[Music]
[Applause]
you wanna text Jersey but sadly my
fellow fair skinned friend
you are no sportswear expert you see
this is a t-shirt with short sleeves of
five-time world champions Golden State
Warriors and this is a jersey with no
sleeves of two-time world champion
Stefan curry I think I finally made
chump meat out of the maestro Conan I
think you've worn a suit for far too
long buddy
have a good one first of all I want to
thank you Michael for shooting that
video inside the giant coffin that you
live in
odd choice but your choice I'm also
sorry Michael though that of Alameda
California but you are dead wrong you
are completely dead wrong that was a
Jets jersey that managed sylvia's was
wearing don't believe me check out this
footage shot recently at an autograph
convention on Long Island featuring
current Jets quarterback Josh McCown
there you go man thank you have a good
one hi mr. McCowan will you sign my
Jersey sure do you have one for me to
sign what the hell you talking about
that's not a Jersey
this is a Jersey haven't you ever seen
me play yeah you thought you thought
you thought that was a jersey and you
know why because there's a lot of
[ __ ] and spread online these days by
guys like Michael Lee evaluated this is
all your fault Michael Lee of Alameda
California no more autographs
so the challenge still stands you think
you've spotted an Arab go on our show
reported at team koco.com / ha ha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you have
what it takes to make jump meat out of
the maestro alright let's demand fine
[Applause]
you